hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar use of echo acoustic liquid
handling in functional genomics
screening of retinal ganglion cells i am
michelle action of labyrinth and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by elaborate and brought to
you by website to learn more please
visit www.gfi.com/webmonitor mew want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation click
on the support tab found at the
top-right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
asks question box located on the far
left of your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speakers Derek
wells be the assistant professor of the
Department of Ophthalmology at the
University of California San Diego and
Ian Russell the senior product manager
at website for complete biography on our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of your screen our speakers
will now begin their presentations
introduction there before I get started
here what I'd like to do is give you a
very brief introduction into lab site as
a company lab site was founded almost 20
years ago and was the first company to
use sound energy to transfer fluids or
both drug development and life science
research the key benefit to our acoustic
transfer technology is the ability to
transfer low nan leader to low micro
litre volumes of fluid with extremely
high precision and accuracy in 2011
dynamic fluid analysis of proprietary
technology was introduced and that
enabled our echo liquid handling systems
to automatically adjust for properties
such as viscosity and surface tension
across a broad range of fluid types
without any user intervention and I'll
go into this in a little bit more detail
on a later slide this technology has
greatly expanded the echo liquid handler
capabilities for use in many different
applications and has led to a strong
adoption of the echo liquid handler in
fields such as genomics and synthetic
biology supporting higher level
automation of our customers workflows
lab site offers a complimentary robotic
platform that enables the integration of
the echo liquid handler with additional
devices for a completely hands-free
experience
with adoption of acoustic liquid
transfer technology in the genomic space
there did come a need for a system that
could build larger volumes faster this
need was filled in 2013 with the launch
of the echo 5 to 5 instrument and this
has become our preferred system for
genomic applications where larger
reaction volumes are preferred not
showing on this slide is the very recent
acquisition of lab site by Beckman
Coulter life sciences now bringing two
leading technology platforms under the
same roof
you
okay let me tell you a little bit about
the technology that provides the
foundation for the echo liquid handler
the echo liquid handler uses sound
energy to move liquids from a source
well to a destination well that is
positioned above the source in an
inverted orientation at a high level the
process is relatively simple sound
energy created by an acoustic transducer
it's focused at the surface of the fluid
to create fluid droplets of a highly
controlled volume these droplets are
then ejected from the surface with
sufficient velocity to reach the target
well which can either be dry as in the
example shown in the cartoon or already
containing fluid depending on the
instrument the droplet will either be a
2.5 nano liter or a 25 nano liter
droplet and volume to transfer larger
volumes is simply the system simply
transfers multiple droplets in quick
succession the systems typically
transfer anywhere between 200 and 500
droplets per second because the
transducer can be aligned with any
source and any destination well the
system is capable of any well to any
well transfer key benefits to this
technology is that there is no physical
contact with the sample in the well so
that maintains sample integrity the
energy is very low energy the droplet
size is highly consistent either 2.5
nanometers or 25 nano liters in volume
and it is rapid influx and flexible
transferring 200 to 500 droplets per
second
now with anything it's not quite this
simple and so I do want to dig into some
of the the key underlying technologies
that we have driving this acoustic
transfer to ensure the high accuracy and
precision of the liquid transfers lab
site uses a process we call dynamic
fluid analysis to interrogate the
content of the source well this utilizes
the ability of the transducer to not
only admit sound energy but also did
that detect the reflected sound energy
or echoes much like sonar medical Archer
sound as an example of this ability what
you are looking at is a representative
cartoon of the detection of sound energy
reflected from the bottom of the plate
the bottom of the well and the surface
of the liquid each of those reflections
has a time and amplitude component which
change based upon the composition of the
liquid the important benefit of this
technology is that it enables the echo
liquid handler to support a very broad
array of different fluid types including
cell lysate s-- various reagents at
varying concentrations even those
including glycerol and various
biomolecules all without the operator
having to make any adjustments to the
instrument either prior to or during the
transfer
now I'm going to switch gears slightly
and introduce the echo product line
I provides a little bit more detail into
the products offered by lab sites the
echo liquid handler product line is
composed of three main instrument
families the echo five to five the echo
550 series and the echo 650 series these
instruments differ in terms of their
speed and types of volume they excel in
transferring the echo 550 and 650 series
instruments offer that 2.5 nanometer
resolution droplet that I described
previously and our recommended line of
instruments for drug development
the echo 5 to 5 instrument on the other
hand offers a 25 nano liter droplet
resolution and is ideal for workflows
such as genomics we're building larger
volumes as required all these
instruments are supported by a catalog
of acoustically qualified microplates
offered by lab sites what is not shown
on this slide is a variety of different
software applications each tailored to
meet the types of workflows of interest
to our customers and the services that
we offer to ensure that you were able to
focus on your science at hand
so what are the benefits of acoustic
liquid handling
the benefits of acoustic liquid handling
really fall into four main categories
first one is maximizing the lab budget
definitely increasing data quality
thirdly speeding up assay design and
execution and lastly the ability to
fully automate complex workflows in the
next two slides I'm going to dive into
two of those benefits in more detail
when you take into consideration the
ability to miniaturize assays using the
echo liquid handler our customers have
been able to achieve up to a hundredfold
reduction in reagent usage that also
translates the less sample consumption
which can be particularly important for
those with limited or particularly
valuable sample types
liddie of the echo liquid handler to
perform any well to any well transfers
extremely rapidly in many cases complex
workflows can be significantly sped up
although this is only one example in the
example shown here an 18 hour workflow
involving sample pooling in enzymatic
assemblies was reduced to only three
hours using the echo liquid handler
saving fifteen hours of time
what I've given you is an overview of
the echo liquid handler family all these
instruments are extremely simple to use
are ready to go out of the box and be
easily integrated into larger automated
solutions and share the same underlying
acoustic contact free transfer
technology
that I want to thank you for all your
attention and will now turn over to
Derek who's going to present on some of
the work that he's been doing using the
echo liquid handler thank you
so thank you so much for joining us
today we're going to be talking about
functional genomic screening in retinal
ganglion cells
so first a disclosure nothing in this
presentation should be construed as an
endorsement for lab site or its products
on behalf of the UC regents or UC San
Diego
now
lab has been interested in developing
novel therapies for a group of eye
diseases called optic neuropathies these
are all characterized by the death of
retinal ganglion cells or our GCS but
since this might be a diverse audience I
figured we'd spend some time on
background so shown here is a
cross-section of a brain and eyeball cut
right down the middle with an enlarged
view of the retina
cartoon of a single retinal ganglion
cell
light hits the eye and is focused on to
the retina on to various spots on the
retina
that light is sent processed by
photoreceptors into an electrochemical
signal that's then sent over to the
retinal ganglion cells the signal is
actually processed by the retinal
ganglion cells and then transmitted down
the optic nerve to higher order centers
in the brain as shown here not results
in vision now I've showed one retinal
ganglion cell but in reality there's
about a million of these lining the
human retina with each one representing
about a pixel of vision and of course
there's a million retinal ganglion cells
then if you look in the optic nerve
there'd be approximately 1 million axons
now shown here is a typical fundus photo
of a normal healthy optic nerve and
retina showing the optic disk which is
the confluence of all the retinal
ganglion cell axons before they exit the
eye as the optic nerve then the question
is what is glaucoma
so in glaucoma there is a death of these
retinal ganglion cells I'm showing you
now the same fundus photo but with a
little cartoon of retinal ganglion cells
what they would look like again I'm
showing you 12 it's not a million just
to make things more clear
in glaucoma these axons get damaged at
the optic nerve head at a structure
called the lamina crib osa
in response to that injury there's a
retrograde injury signal that propagates
up the axon and triggers an active
genetic program of axon degeneration
and cell death
and this starts off in these peripheral
or somewhat peripheral retinal ganglion
cells but it continued that propagates
progresses and it moves closer and
closer to the center of the retina
called the fovea and as you lose these
axons combined with the changes in the
optic disk structure you get this
characteristic shape of the optic nerve
called cupping which is sort of a very
characteristic of glaucoma now I'm going
to show that same animation but this
time I'm going to show a visual field
test which is what a patient would do
when they're being evaluated for
glaucoma
so that little black spot in the visual
field here is normal that's the
physiologic blind spot and keep in mind
that everything is reversed so that the
inferior visual field is a process by
the superior retina so at first there is
this damage to the optic nerve and that
triggers the degeneration and cells that
but initially you have more of a no
ganglion cells than you need so even
though you've lost well ganglion cells
we don't see that as a loss of vision on
a visual field test however as this
progresses more and more you eventually
dip into your reserve of retinal
ganglion cells and it starts to
functionally disconnect entire swaths of
retina from the brain leading to these
visual field defects and again this
progresses and if you lose more and more
retinal ganglion cells it gets closer
and closer to the center of vision and
some patients sadly enough even despite
treatment can lose all of their retinal
ganglion cells and also because of the
limited capacity for adult neurogenesis
this vision loss is essentially
permanent and so in 2019 we can't
restore vision and the only thing we can
do is to lower eye pressure in summary
glaucoma is an axon injury disease of
retinal ganglion cells and the only
treatment is to lower eye pressure and
it's interesting right because I give
this introduction to glaucoma
are really is very little mention of
high pressure you know almost 50% of
patients never have an elevated eye high
pressure and the reason it's so central
to glaucoma therapy is simply because it
is our only modifiable risk factor so
what our lab has been very interested in
is you know can we identify a neuro
protective strategy that might
complement IOP lowering and the idea
behind a neuro protective strategy is
that it might interfere directly with
that retrograde injury signal in
response to that axon injury or with the
active genetic programs of axon
degeneration and our cell death and by
directly protecting the retinal ganglion
cell we think we can hopefully improve
the options for glaucoma patients so you
know over the years lots of people have
tried lots of neuro protective
strategies so what we thought we might
try and do is set up a comprehensive and
unbiased screen of potential drug
targets we developed a phenotypic screen
using primary notes retinal ganglion
cells to interfere with gene function we
used the genetic technology of RNA
interference initially mediated by small
interfering RNAs or si RNAs and each of
these would knock down a target gene if
the target gene is involved in cell
death then its knockdown should promote
survival as diagrams here in this
cartoon to do this since we were going
to work with primary retinal ganglion
cells we needed a way of delivering RNA
to the cell in a fashion that was sort
of amenable to high throughput screening
fortunately we came across this magnetic
nanoparticle called neuro mag from AHS
Biosciences and what we do is we couple
that on a particle to nucleic acid and
as as simple as simply mixing them
together and then adding them to the
media
the cell culture plates is placed on a
magnet which we actually just keep in
our incubator it brings down the
magnetic nanoparticles probably
increases their local concentration at
the bottom of the well and leads to
uptake of the nanoparticles and for
instance if we put in a gfp mrna we get
really really nice transfection
efficiencies and the system is very
amenable since it's simply a mix and ad
type system it's very amenable to height
you put screening shown here is the
bright field image of our primary
retinal ganglion cells and the GFP
fluorescence after we've transect them
with GFP mRNA now the system works great
for delivering RNA it does not work well
for delivering plasmid probably because
of the additional barrier having to get
to the nucleus so then the next
challenge was we had to obtain si RNA
libraries so we worked with and NCBI in
cats too to get that so we had multiple
si RNA libraries and they came in place
where the s RNA was approximately 10
micromolar so we had to make
intermediate plates and for that we made
intermediate plates using these v-bottom
polystyrenes now we would typically fill
them using the Kombi just bulk liquid
dispensing we dispense 20 microliters of
up to them
into all the wells and 100 nanometers of
neuro maghen again that's all mixed
together and just bulk dispensed we
would then transfer the SI RNA library
using the lab site echo now typically we
screen at one nano molar si RNA and our
source wells the ones from MCATs were
coming in at 10 micromolar did that a
96-well plate we would have a final
volume of 100 micro molar we needed to
do approximately a 1 to 10,000 dilution
of the SI RNA which meant that you we
would use the echo to transfer 10 nano
liters now fortunately that's right in
the sweet spot for the echo so we would
just go through and use the echo to
transfer over the SI RNA to these pre
dispensed v-bottom intermediate plates
and we would fill them up we leave the
edge columns open for controls once we'd
finished with our intermediate place we
returned to the athlete plates that will
actually be used to culture the cells
and these are standard tissue culture
coated nunc plates we would coat them
with PDL and laminin and then we would
transfer the library from those v-bottom
plates using a liquidator just
essentially a 96-well our 96 head
multi-channel pipettes and then the idea
would be to have the cells go on top of
that in a reverse transfection paradigm
so to get the cells we would use p0
wild-type black six pups and we would
immuno pan them using anti thigh one
coated plates
from there we would seed these into the
multiple dishes again using a combi and
we I'm showing the screen for 96 wells
but we've done this with 3d for more
plates and 1536 well plates and
essentially the workflow is the same so
we use the combi to add the cells on top
now remember there's already a
transection mix sitting in each of these
weld with each well getting a different
si RNA now either because of the
isolation of these retinal ganglion
cells which necessarily axon amazes them
or simply about something about the way
we are culturing them we get pretty
profound death over the next three days
which sort of makes sense right if you
access autumn eyes the retinal ganglion
cell it does die that's kind of the idea
behind glaucoma so we're using this
natural cell debt after isolation as our
selective pressure as our model of
injury then what we need to do is figure
out which wells that we've intervened on
that have increased in survival have
increases in survival so it's done this
two different ways what we initially did
this we use the Salam accession but more
recently we've been using the molecular
devices image Express and we simply
ought to have an automated imaging
platform where we go through and take
pictures of all the wells and then
automated image analysis to quantify the
number of surviving neurons and when
we've done our smaller scale screens
this has worked just fine for larger
scale screens where we're up into the
multiple tens of thousands of wells we
have found it easier to adapt the
platform to self ever glow which is a
reagent from pro mega as an ATP based
luminescent assay and then we just used
a BMG plate reader to quantify survival
and again if we're doing large screens
we find out to be a little bit easier so
the work started with the Chi know and
the reason we started with the Chi know
was well there's a few reasons first
it's a small percentage of the genome
about 2 or 3 percent of the genome so it
makes things easier to get started
second the contents to be rather
bioactive and fine
if we find anything it's pretty easy to
envision making drugs because of the
rich history of medicinal chemistry when
it comes to developing kinase inhibitors
so shown here is a histogram of the
results from our first keynote screen so
there's just a little under 700 genes in
the mouse genome we had three si rnase
per gene and shown here the histogram of
survival as you can see most si rnase
cluster around the zero or slightly
negative survival which makes sense
most si RNAs when they knock down their
target don't do anything to survival or
if anything they decrease survival what
we were interested in is what were those
si RNAs that are out here who is when
we've knocked down the target gene you
get an increase in survival suggesting
that that target gene is involved in
cell death the top hits in the screen
where the actual 3ala goes against do
leucine zipper kinase also known as dl k
very satisfying but actually the number
to hit in the screen where the three
srna's against MK k 7 which at the time
was the only known substrate of dl k to
validate what we were finding on plastic
had some invivo relevance we turned to
Aaron D Antonio's flocks dl k mice in
which the addition of cree leads to an
incomplete kinase domain and loss of
function
so again given that glaucoma is an axon
injury disease we used the quick and
dirty model of optic nerve crush to
validate dlk
first we would in traditionally inject
virus that delivers Cree
and that transduces retinal ganglion
cells into either flocks dlk mice or the
wild-type control we would then wait
seven days to allow the virus to
complete its life cycle and for the
extent VLK to turn over at that point we
would then crush the optic nerve
mechanically with a five second crush
ten days given that you've now injured
the axons of the retinal ganglion cells
you'll see death of retinal ganglion
cell so we quantify that by staining
flat mils of retina and then doing
automated image analysis shown here is a
retinal flat mount that's been stained
for retinal ganglion cells and it's
replaced with the normal population of
retinol getting wind zone 10 days after
crush in control mice in which dlk is
present you see the tort sort of typical
two-thirds loss of rebel ganglion cells
however in mice which carry the fluxed
VLK allele the addition of cream
quite robustly increases the amount of
survival that you see ten days later now
it was nice because this work was
actually independently validated by Joe
Lou Cox group at Genentech so they also
showed that the loss of the LK leaves
you increased survival retinal ganglion
cells in vivo and actually if you went
18 weeks out you could see that that
survival was still maintained which was
nice and we were not just delaying cell
death but preventing and what this
taught us was that our in vitro platform
of using mouse primary retinal ganglion
cells could teach us something about
these in vivo optic neuropathy models
finally because of course we are
interested in ultimately developing
glaucoma therapies to protect you know
retinal ganglion cells have been injured
in a glaucoma model we turn to the rat
laser model which you laser the
trabecular meshwork raised eye pressure
and measure the number of surviving
retinal ganglion cells either in the
retina or optic nerve about six weeks
later and we used a small molecule
inhibitor that has activity against the
okay
packaged it in such a way that it would
release over you know approximately the
six week period when injected in
traveling and show that that small on to
inhibit or improved survival now it was
interesting when we were doing this work
we noticed that the effect of the drug
towards a circuit which again is an
inhibitor against the okay would give
much greater survival then when we
genetically knockdown T okay in vitro as
shown here and it made us think that
perhaps the drug was doing some other
target in addition to deal kidding that
was improving our activity in vitro so
to identify that missing target what we
did is repeated our kinase screen
looking for the Chi no but this time we
started with dlk already knocked down
and we repeated now of course G okay
doesn't come out anymore because he
okayed already knocked down in every
well but now what came out were the V
srna's against LD k or leucine zipper
kinase we made the leucine zipper kinase
knockout melissa conditional knockout
bred it to the conditional D okay and
what we showed in vitro when we added
adenovirus to transduce primary retinal
ganglion cells with Cree is that the
addition of cream would give you a small
increase in flocks deal cane retinal
ganglion cells remember what I said
before
genetic knockout of deal K by itself in
vitro doesn't do that much but it's
certainly above baseline but the knocked
out of LD k does essentially nothing to
survival of course if you knock out both
dl k and LD k we saw this very robust
increase in survival and this was done
in primary retinal ganglion cells but we
also showed that there was additional
survival in vivo in the optic nerve
crush model now it turns out this gave
us a nice opportunity because LD cain't
knockout by itself doesn't really do
much to survival I mean those are the
triangles you can barely even see here
of the controls however if you
additionally knocked out dl k in this
setting of an LD k knocked out you get
this very robust in
shown here so we thought hey this maybe
gives us an opportunity to sensitize the
screen to things that are in the dlk
pathway and that increased
signal-to-noise might allow us to not
just screen the kind but to screen the
entire mouse genome so we did we've
actually done this now in multiple
screens but shown here are the results
of screening approximately 18,000 si
RNAs and these are little mini pools of
four srna's per well it was satisfying
that the well that can change the mini
pool against VLK was actually the number
one hit so the screen in general was
working to identify things that the okay
pathway because it identified plk
but when we went to confirm the other
genes that were increasing survival by
ordering new snrnas against those we
really found almost nothing was
confirming the reason for this is likely
the lack of specificity of Si RNA so
unfortunately these are pretty none
specific you know when you have an FA
RNA
you've got your 21 nucleotide sequence
which I'm sure matches a single mRNA in
the genome and so that's rather specific
however these snrnas also have this six
to seven nucleotide seed sequence shown
in orange and because it's only six to
seven nucleotides it's much less
specific and so it binds to the three
prime UTR of multiple mRNAs and leads to
silencing so unfortunately the ratio of
things that are nonspecific to specific
it's probably something like twenty to
one or a hundred one and so it really
makes it difficult to D effects through
the noise we try to address this two
different ways first was seed correction
we know the seed of every si RNA and we
know that we sample that seed in the
context of different s RNA sequences
what we can do is keep track of how that
seed non-specifically is affecting
survival and then we can generate a
handicap score so you can imagine for
the CG you a AGCO shown here in red
every time an S RNA had that seed there
was this increase in survival so if we
see a target s RNA that we're interested
in and it's got that seed it needs to
have even more than twofold survival to
be interesting so we essentially can go
through and re handicap all the snrnas
the second thing we did to try to deal
with this off target issue letting
haystack analysis so again we know the
seed in every snrna moreover we know all
the potential off targets that it could
be hitting so what we do is we keep
track of the seed the off targets and
the effect on survival through every
well and if we've screened enough wells
and we've done screens of almost 60,000
snrnas
we can then do is figure out are there
genes that tend to correlate with that
feed and with survival so for instance
in all the wells that have increased
survival we might tend to see seeds that
silence BBC 3 or Puma so this is another
way of getting at potential hits but
again this is sort of finally
dramatically D convoluting the data to
try to find something interesting
amongst all this noise it would be much
better to have a system where we could
screen that simply doesn't have all the
noise and so what Kevin's an just a
second the second issue that we ended up
with was we would do these screens we'd
get these very interesting candidates
but then we had some validated and again
with all this noise affarin a's we
weren't going to be satisfied with
validations that use snrna we really
needed knockouts now we were obtaining
the flocked mice for a lot of these
candidates like socks 11 or MEF 2a and
we would import them eyes that go
through quarantine we breed them up we'd
eventually have enough mice that we
could isolate primary retinal ganglion
cells from them and we could do the in
vitro assay by adding a decree to these
conditional knockouts and if we saw
increased survival as you're seeing here
with Fox 11 or here with nephew a we
knew that indeed our results from the si
RNA screens were validated but that was
a lot of work and you know we have this
great height rupin system but this is as
low throughput as it gets so we needed
something different and that's why we
turn to CRISPR screen so the way this
would work is we would provide a guide
RNA to a various various targets that
binds to caz 9 katherine comes in and
using its two nucleus domains creates a
double-stranded break that
double-stranded break is repaired by the
non-homologous end joining machinery but
because there's no template there you
end up with mutations and
chosen targets that are in the coding
sequence of the gene you end up with
frameshift mutations that cause a loss
of function so the strategy was we would
isolate retinal ganglion cells from mice
that already have Kaz 9 in every cell
these are Fang Jiang's
roasted 26 mice which have constitutive
expression of the strep pyogenes cat 9
and all we would have to do is we don't
deliver Kaz right now we're just
responsible for delivering the tRNA but
as I showed you before both with the SI
RNA data and with the GFP mRNA data RNA
we were pretty good at delivery
so the way we would do this is we would
order an ala go against any given target
so for instance let's say socks 11 comes
out of the screen and we want to
validate socks 11 we would order an el
ago that has a grna sequence targeting
sucks 11 on the 5 prime end that all ago
would have the g7 promoter and on the 3
prime end that all ago would have a
piece of the grna scaffold or the
traitor sequence and because the entire
sequence is less than 60 nucleotides
that is a relatively inexpensive primer
to have synthesized and then we would
have a second primer which has the
remainder of the grna scaffold or tracer
sequence we could anneal these two and
we would transfer them to these low dead
volumes echo plates and then use the
echo to transfer these G RNAs then we
would use a PCR machine to do elongation
of those annealed primers and what you
end up generating is what's shown up
here you end up generating the entire G
RNA sequence with a t7 promoter up at
the 5 prime end
then what we needed to do was we run the
PCR did extension they what we need to
do is from that PCR product use the t7
promoter to do in vitro transcription we
would use the hi scribe click g7
high-yield RNA synthesis kit again we
would use the echo to transfer the right
amounts of kit the right amounts of our
pcr template that we had just made and
we would do the in vitro transcription
and what that would generate is lots of
in vitro transcribed grna we would then
purify that in vitro transcribed G RNA
and used that for the transduction and
although initially in our screens we
were doing things in which d neuro mag
was transferred via the Kombi in bulk
transfer now we were transferring the
neuro mag with the echo and doing the
preparation of the transduction [ __ ]
all with the echo software and that
seemed to be that that's worked pretty
well so then as we generate lists of
potential targets all we do now is order
a new 55 nucleotide sequence G RNA in
vitro transcribe the G RNA and use that
to test whether there is relevant
biology
so does this whole system work well the
first thing we had to show was that the
system wasn't toxic we were delivering
you know this RNAs that were
approximately a hundred nucleotides long
and so using the primary retinal
ganglion cells we showed that in general
there was no nonspecific activity of the
G RNAs they weren't toxic next we made a
series of G RNAs against dlk right
because that was our positive control
and we tested difference and what we
showed is that these G RNAs when you put
them into primary retinal ganglion cells
isolated from wild-type mice do not
increase survival because there's no CAD
line to do CRISPR editing control and
grna don't do don't increase survival
even when given to CAD 9r DC's but feel
K targeting tRNAs when selectively given
to caz nine expressing retinal ganglion
cells gave this very nice increase in
survival and one thing that we noticed
was it didn't really matter which exons
we were targeting we saw a little bit of
variability but maybe not as much as one
would expect and the amount of survival
the second thing that was maybe a little
bit interesting is that when we combined
G RNAs we really didn't see much
improvement it's sort of maxed out as
shown here when we combined we didn't
see much improvement
I misspoke here we've used the deal ksi
pool to knock down the okay and we're
combining with the LD k gene RNA the one
I just described is actually here where
we're knocking down dl k + LD k have not
done with an SI pool we've also done
over we've knocked down both dl k + LD k
only with g rnas
next we want to look at off target
cutting so we chose an SI RNAs re AG RNA
sequence that would disrupt a
restriction site so if we were getting
good cutting by our Taz 9 we should not
get good cutting by the vgl 2
restriction site because the mutagenesis
should disrupt recognition by VG l2 and
indeed we would show we could show that
if we amplified the VLK locus that the
addition of the grna targeting dlk would
create this new band that's not
digestible with VG l2 however when we
look at the various off targets we
really weren't seeing much maybe a
little bit for one of them but in
generally we're not seeing much off
targeting which was satisfying we looked
at whether we needed to have homozygous
or heterozygous mice and it turns out it
really did not make much of a difference
that if you put the G RNA into either
Kaz 9 heterozygote RG C's or CAD 9
homozygous RDCs
we essentially got very similar levels
of gene editing maybe with some trend
towards homozygous being better if we
looked at the mutagenesis that we
created we saw that when we put in 2g
rnase we would often see in versions of
the intervening sequence or deletions of
the intervening sequence but only
occasionally would we see individual
mutations where only one site but not
the other is being utilized as shown in
construct 9 if we put in a single G RNA
we saw the typical cutting where the
mutagenesis are sort of typically small
deletions and they're centered around
the 3rd and 4th nucleotide just upstream
of the pam sequence and using this
technique we were able to produce
mutagenesis that was approximately 50%
of the population of primary retinal
ganglion cells so we've used that
technology now to validate various
target genes I have a slide on that here
what you're seeing here are cast 9
retinal ganglion cells isolated in vitro
in which we have created in vitro
transcribed G RNAs against various
targets a tf2 MF to a Sox 11 and June
and shown that when we add these guys
individually we don't see much increase
in survival but when we knock them out
in a combinatorial fashion we see
relatively nice survival in vitro and
we've done sort of optimizations of dose
and it really does tend to be that for
us about 30 nanograms of sgrna or
synthetic guide RNA is sort of the the
sweet spot for producing knockouts but
now that we know that what we can do is
we can consider screening we have this
echo based system where we can transfer
we can do all this synthesis of G RNAs
and sort of small-scale per well that
means we can do a lot of different wells
we can transfer things using the echo
and do screens so to prove that a screen
was doable we actually use the deal cane
grna in and our D sees that are lacking
ldk and if we put in control guides we
see that we have a very consistent lack
of survival or death at baseline but
when we put in in various wells in 3d
for ball format guide RNAs that have
been in vitro transcribed using the echo
system we see increases in survival and
although there is some noise there's
such clear separation between background
that this makes for a good screen so we
are now in the process of screening a
library that targets the mouse kai gnome
to see if there are kindnesses that we
missed with SI RNA based screening
either because of the noise or because
we need a knockout rather than knockdown
to see the biology and we're hoping that
this new system allows us to identify
new kinase targets using our prior
system we've developed this model of
cell death in which injury leads to
activation of dlk lzk
and various downstream targets to
mediate cell death in conclusion we have
developed a high trooper method for
functional genomic screening in Mouse
primary record gaming zone we started
off with RNA AI based screening but now
have moved to CRISPR based screening and
we've used a variety of machines but one
that has been really enabling for us is
the lab site echo simply because it
allows very small volume transfers this
has been part of a long-standing
collaboration with Don's acts of course
I want to dig thank Don and the rest of
his lab including Sydney John who is now
at lab sites you can't have made a lot
of the G RNAs Vinnie who did some of the
conceptualization of the grna method
pinguin katie who did some of the work
creating these we have a Hydrabad screen
courser UC san diego with carl Wallen
and myself Risa omits homage actually
I'm actually get a lot of credit here
omits the postdoc in my lab has done a
lot of this work and also a
collaboration with Robert Weinreb thank
you very much for listening and I'll now
take some questions
Thank You Derek and Ian for your
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen will answer as many
questions as we have time for the first
question is most vendors sell guide RNAs
in which the tracer RNA and the CRO RNA
are two separate molecules if you try
that and how does it work
so we have actually we tip that what I
showed was where we were creating an in
vitro transcribed 100 nucleotide ish
grna the kind of chimeric grna in which
the tracer and the crispr RNA are fused
into one when we've compared that versus
some of the commercial vendors to p
system we see almost a log loss of
activity so for whatever reason in our
system when we break this up into two
pieces it has not worked nearly as well
now the we've tried the Dharma Kahn
system there there CRNAs and there are
traits or RNA we haven't necessarily
tried all the different vendors out
there but but just when we have tried it
it has not worked particularly well and
we really don't know why that is because
obviously in the endogenous system in
bacteria it is a two-piece system so
really one would think it should work
and but in our hands not as well
thank you our next question is how do
you choose your guide on a target
there's a variety of criteria that go
into choosing our guides so you know we
have used there's a ton of websites out
there that I'll kind of predict off
target effects we I think have sort of
vectored towards using the broad
Institute's on an off target ranker that
gives us a general list of grna s now
because we are doing g7 based
transcription ideally our G RNAs would
start with 3 G's so it'd be the motif
gjg and 17 ng g however we've realized
that we really don't need to start with
3 G's we can start with 2 and actually
we've even started with just one and
it's perfectly fine for t 7
transcription in our hands also because
we don't want to throw out some of those
really highly ranked G RNAs we've made G
RNAs that are not the 20 nucleotide
spacers but only 19 or 18 or 21 and
those all seem to work equally well so
anyway you can move that first G
anywhere in the first four nucleotides
and it seems to be just fine we try to
make sure that the grna targets common
exons ideally we want the CRISPR cutting
site between that third and fourth
nucleotide to fall within a restriction
site only because it makes the
downstream quantification of cutting so
much easier because as I showed all you
do that is a PCR to flank that region
digest the PCR product with the
restriction site and there's an inverse
correlation between the amounts of
restriction cutting and the amount of
CRISPR editing and so that works out
works pretty easily
the grna sites tend to be between sort
of the 5th and 65th percentile of the of
this coding sequence although that's not
our rule that comes from the
bioinformatics software we do like to
have G RNAs that target both mouse and
human although I haven't talked about it
today we have been now doing this work
in IPS derived human retinal ganglion
cells and so it's nice and we have one
grna that we can cross shop across the
two different platforms and I think the
last thing I guess thing we've done
recently there was a paper that came out
at the end of I think last year by Graf
at all that showed that there are a few
of these motifs like GCC or Tiki in the
distal part the park next to the pam
where you want to avoid those for good
grna design so we've been avoiding that
we're not sure if it makes a difference
but we've been doing that you know in
general we pay a lot more attention to
bioinformatics predictions of off-target
cutting than we do of on target cutting
because we don't see so much variability
in the on targets but we know that the
off targets and that was our whole
history with SI RNAs that can be problem
so so that's sort of our priority
great thank you multiple papers have
shown chemically modified guide RNAs
have improved editing capability you
tried these so we have now keep in mind
we are very limited in what we can use
because we use the t7 polymerase to make
our G RNA so a lot of these chemically
modified G rnase come from chemical
synthesis and then you can put in all
sorts of modified bases however for us
the only one that's really compatible
with t7 is the two prime fluoro G RNA
and so we did that we transcribe these
2.40 G RNAs and we saw absolutely no
difference in editing if anything maybe
it was a little bit worse
our next question is does the echo
require calibrating for each fluid type
but so the the echo does not require any
calibration by the user irrespective of
the type of fluid that they're using lab
site is calibrating all the echo liquid
handlers in the factory before they go
out and the calibrations capture very
very broad fluid categories so for
example that might be surfactant
containing fluids buffers alone or
perhaps buffers that have are viscous in
nature because of glycerol or some other
viscous material being in there those
high-level categories are selected by
the user and then it's the dynamic fluid
analysis technology which enables the
echo to adjust on the fly for the
nuances of the particular fluid that is
being transferred so it's very simple to
use it's simply a the user just needs to
understand the high-level category in
which the fluid lies they select the
appropriate calibration that is offered
on the instrument and then they start
the fluid transfer process
thank you our next question is can you
use any type of plate with the echo
that is a good question for the
destination plate the answer is yes
provided that it is an z slash compliant
so the instrument gripper supports any
plate types that are automation friendly
and the flask compliant
we even have customers who are using
slides or petri dish types of
consumables where you can purchase
carriers for those now on the source
plate side so this would be the micro
plates from which you are transferring
your fluid we do require that you use an
eco qualified plate these are plates
that lab sites provides or offers and we
go through a lot of effort to ensure
that those plates are acoustically
compatible and will provide the optimal
fluid transfer when used with the echo
liquid handler technology
how does the echo system ensure there is
no cross-contamination
this is of course a very important
aspect of any liquid handler the echo
liquid handler if it wasn't a parent in
my presentation does not use any tips or
pins or anything that physically touches
the fluid so it's purely the sound
energy that is generating those droplets
and ejecting them out
so with that you completely eliminate
any potential cost contamination that is
resulting from tips involved in the
transfer process which can be a fairly
major source of cross contamination if
is depending on the the type of system
and the fluids being transferred there
on the other aspect there is the dynamic
fluid analysis is constantly adjusting
the parameters of the acoustic transfer
process to ensure that the transfer is
optimal and that we maintain that high
degree of accuracy and precision for the
volumes that are being transferred
thank you again Derek and Ian for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor website for underwriting
today's educational webcast before we go
I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions questions we did
not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speakers via
the contact information you provided at
the time of registration lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event until
next time goodbye